[Music]
[Applause]
it's worth asking how long will Fox keep
using the 20th century logo in the 21st
century will they be watching a screener
in 2345 and some intern will finally
pipe up you know we really should update
that and the studio heads will not
quietly in collective realization
nice try DreamWorks but you're not going
to distract me from loading this 47
seconds of two logos why should pot of
time yet another DreamWorks movie opens
with a shot of a storybook and Once Upon
a Time rip the only thing left to do to
ensure brand loyalty is to now show a
montage of a character doing disgusting
Shrek style poo things wow these tools
sure do look a lot like stitch from
Disney's lilo and stay hey where'd all
these lawyers come from bergens didn't
know how to sing or dance or even hug
sure these Bergen assholes are assholes
but resorting to wedgies as a form of
communication meaning at all made them
feel so happy they started a tradition
I'm not surprised
trolls are apparently 40% hair and 60%
pure MDMA once a year every year the
Bergen would gather around the troll
tree to taste happiness well I once a
year if eating a troll mix the Bergin's
feels so good wouldn't they be gobbling
them up by the bushel you know there's a
Bergen named Larry that's totally
addicted to that and it's sneaking them
off at a ziploc bag or something and
binging at home
[Music]
in the hall of the Mountain King gets a
hip-hop update and Edvard Grieg is
popping and locking in his grave
seriously the Virgin's eat trolls but
they also have a doughnut shop doesn't
that make them happy too how can you
sadly eat a doughnut
they're lighter fluid looks more like
Nickelodeon slime than lighter fluid
wait maybe that is Nickelodeon slime we
just didn't know how flammable it was
that really changes the tone of double
dare this is a very special Roasters how
do they feed the whole town with two
tiny grills and the tiny trolls doesn't
the happiness dissipate when they've
divided up into parts also sure we're
about to see some of the trolls escaped
here but the bergens have been doing
this for years
we should probably pour one up for all
those poor bastards who weren't around
for Anna Kendrick to team up with Justin
Timberlake and save the world with music
as there is one amongst us who has never
tasted a troll talking about me wait
Prince gristle was less than a year old
and he can ride trikes walk and talk
with that kind of growth rate the older
Bergin should be in wheelchairs by the
time they're 25 it is my sacred duty to
initiate you in the ways of true
happiness Bergen or not this should be
filed under the creepy things that
should never be said to a child make me
happy Bobby what the hell are the girls
for then I think I hear something
the trolls are making their escape right
at the time of the troll stuff so you
think they'd be a little quieter about
it sighs and it's in and we already have
our second underwear sight gag
dreamworks you do you also if they're
digging they would have picked up the
axe and slung again but chef apparently
thought this was good enough and called
it a day it was this easy to escape the
troll tree why didn't they do it long
before now she's young i banished from
bergen town forever i know king grizzle
was looking for a scapegoat
why is chef the one that's banished I
mean she just cooks the trolls right she
can't be the only one in town checking
in with him on the regular she will
never ever ever ever be happy meddler
ever but there's a portrait right behind
them of the king and Prince cheesing
since the Prince hadn't had parole
before either this painting was done
today which is some both or they were
previously happy this is where we will
rebuild our civilization unless we've
just had a massive time jump they
couldn't be more than a day's walk from
Bergen town given their tiny legs and
the fact that many of them were slow
during the escape I would think this new
spot is about a half a mile from certain
Bergen death it has everything
we need fresh air clean water and sweet
acoustic I half expected to hear Smash
Mouth all-stars
also a trolls movie in 2016 wait a
straight while the iron is hot also also
7 minutes and 32 seconds into the movies
when we get the title of the movie it's
like 8 percent of the movie already and
now every troll is free to be happy and
live in perfect harmony
my princesses always get stuck watching
the village kids they didn't have anyone
else who could read from the sacred book
of exposition what the hell are these
little things and not trolls and they
weren't in the rescue party from 20
years ago
so the troll race must have been slave
trained and domesticated an entirely new
species for transportation and acoustic
drumming which is pretty goddamn
gruesome okay I can buy that the trolls
have functional photography in this
universe but why does biggie have a
suggested boudoir picture of his minion
in a bikini something's missing we were
almost at the 10-minute mark when I was
where we weren't going to get any
scatological humor in this cocoon thing
I could hear you from a mile away if I
can hear you so can the Bergen but they
haven't the trolls have presumably been
doing routines like this for 20 years
with not one of those preparing them the
targets are going ah hang on I thought
trolls were always happy shouldn't their
funeral be more like New Orleans wakes
also a dump branch showing any
advancement in age this clown troll
worked at a party fell in love got
married and then died also also thanks
to a mortician for searing this
nightmarish image of a clown cruel
corpse into my head I don't do happy but
why not as he's had a traumatic event is
past but he's a troll controls seem to
be genetically predisposed to happiness
but branches all rebellious lee sad
that's like a cow consciously deciding
not to produce milk some folks just
don't want to be happy right but they
are folks they are a species of
perpetually happy trolls so it seems
that they shouldn't be as dismissive of
his behavior they should treat him more
like he's a psychopath interest but
these poor trolls are stuck up in the
air for the entirety of the party
spinning and spinning instead of
enjoying it with their friends below
yeah yeah it's almost like this script
was written by 47 year old dudes that
we're forced to come up with how they
think young Millennials talk looking hey
it was just Lydia is basically the ant
and the grasshopper fable but with
glitter feces and clown corpses
well they always capable of this glitter
supernova and
wouldn't they have tried a test of this
before also poppy is overexcited but
she's not an idiot right the music and
noise is one thing but why would she
authorized this obvious glitter flare
within range of everyone nearby defeat
also the king is right there at the
party shouldn't he at least put a stop
to this but dude's been through the
scourge and escape from the Bergen since
the beginning so the chef has been robed
for the last twenty fifteen years but
hasn't had a width of parole until now
and she's right next to them
she's pretty but I think this troll
village is a little more Pandora than
the filmmakers intended gotcha really
moving can there not be one animated non
Pixar movie that doesn't have that
character poops when scared cliche I
would say you're better than that
but after previously watching this I
know that not to be true so carry on I
guess sakis hair somehow has the
strength to tug firmly against chefs
grasp even though chefs been picking up
the other trolls by the hair until now
chef has access to many other trolls
that she just spent a little more time
looking for them like you know she's
been doing for the past 20 years branch
decimated this invitation when poppy
gave it to him but it's magically
without a scratch here because we need a
reason to like this character also grump
secretly wants to join the fun cliche
when we go to Bergen town with me and
save everyone there are still like 30
trolls left in the village but poppy
goes to the one dude that doesn't get
along with anyone to ask for help you
told me not just with a party and I
threw it anyway it's not throwing the
party that was the problem it was
shooting fireworks in the air that
basically said delicious trolls here
it's my fault they were taken and now I
don't know what to do why don't you try
scrapbooking them the freedom Jesus this
movie cast maybe the two most likable
leads in the world but gave them such
huge character flaws that's impossible
to refer either of them hey any time
poppy see in ten years
branch clearly doesn't expect poppy or
any of the troll to live that long poppy
wasn't gone long enough to let everyone
in which means they got through all the
branches locks and traps meaning his
bunker building skills are horse
[Music]
non-consensual hugging this journey to
Bergen town is suddenly fraught with
peril
look just 20 years ago the king lit a
bunch of slow-ass trolls out here in
less than a day were there many more
trolls that didn't make it during the
trip that we don't know about also if
this is how dangerous the jungle is then
they may be safer with the Bergin's they
just try and eat them once a year
probably surprised us also I know most
kids at this age won't be asking those
questions yet but this is not the best
way to be teaching them about
reproduction poppies walk to Bergen town
takes her through an acid rain storm a
desert and a pink blizzard within the
span of one day branch at coconut
poppy hang on branch must've been
following poppy throughout this journey
right and if so he's casually watched
her get threatened with fire eaten
cooked into an egg and poison but
chooses now to get concerned about her
well-being you're a live branch you know
it you don't know anything poppy and I
can't wait to see the look on your face
when you realize the world isn't all
cupcakes and rainbows
why did Branch come on this excursion
then I know he wanted to get away from
the hugging and singing a troll town but
he could have gone anywhere else you
don't stain your fan okay all the time
that's graces I also like a little
silence poppy decides to behave like a
literal troll too poor branch also how
would poppy a troll that only knows
happiness know such a dark and
foreboding song and where the hell if
she could pack a car this whole time hey
that's a boot and fast food litter and a
car tire there he was here or there
we're humans which is the more
disturbing option so one of these
tunnels lead to the troll tree I wonder
which one this is information her dad
could have given poppy as she was
leaving instead of organizing a hug orgy
one of these tunnels leads to the troll
tree and the others to certain death
yeah if it doesn't the troll tree also
ensure certain death I mean that's where
the trolls have been picked for Bergen
food for many years really cleared up
exactly what I will not be doing rich
it's a high five
the others lead to certain death yeah
perspective for all her faults during
this movie it's apparent poppy would be
excellent at cinemasins shark-attack nom
nom nom jellyfish and family Turkey
Snowman Dolphin helicopter hat supper
lucky to do what gearshift
way too much of this sounds it can we
hug movie continues to derive humor out
of various characters soiling themselves
in terror you're telling me there's only
one forward restaurant in town but there
are three non earth
as appalled as I am to see a gorilla
song used in a subpar movie I'm also
wondering why the bergens would be
sending this lyric I thought it was a
matter of civic pride that they aren't
happy
yes miserable yeah which means they have
any trauma so what you're saying is if
you with them each rules then they will
all be happy I would assume that will
only make a few of them happy and the
rest of them extremely resentful sad
Todd first on how to Jeff get back into
the city if she were banished there's a
gate at the front of the city a huge ass
door on the castle at least two guards
here second what the hell took her so
long branch and poppy had been on this
journey for what seems like forever but
a chef had a head start and a thousand
percent more stride length she should
have been here ages ago
all these trolls have beautiful natural
voices but there's always one asshole
that has that Kanye I am their king
what happened to the John Cleese version
of the King it's been 20 years sure but
young grifoll is under 21 at this point
he couldn't have been Natalie and who
knows how long the Bergen blip I want
answers to these unimportant questions
can what's your name Oh Ricky movie
wastes almost 40 minutes getting to
arguably the second most talented singer
in the SCAF we must all remain calm
especially since at least 3/4 of you
could simply fit between the bars of the
cage and just walk the hell out of here
sorry baby he who controls the trolls
controls the kingdom and I I am bhakti
your adieu unusually transphobic humor
for a modern children's movie in 2016
this super hair ability seems to come
and go good and poppy have used it
before the spider web scatter couldn't
the captured trolls use it to open the
cage while Shep isn't looking I would
like this movie so much more quick with
30% more hair centric oh you think
that's funny
well she's laughing when I bite your
yummy head off which I will not do right
now even though I'm miserable when
you're standing right in front of me ah
oh my dad said the first time should be
special
the second fake out is long enough to
remind me that even though it's only 81
minutes long this movie had to pad its
runtime watching frozen your Roman guard
them with your life
chef gives an incredibly important job
to a young Bergen she just met rather
than taking the trolls with her in a
fanny pack
and bridget is dead there's a Bergen
Beat Magazine who publishes it who
writes the articles there's a cover
story titled and misery but how the hell
do they know how to do that
and why does Bridget have to hide it
anyway this is silly but to be fair it's
only the second silliest video ever made
for this alt poppy how could you
possibly think Craig still alive well
we've still got about 40 minutes left in
this movie then we've heard creaks dead
about 25 times so I'd say it's a real
good book I suppose I told you I don't
think amazingly talented character
refuses to do the thing he's amazingly
talented at cliche yeah why won't you
think of singing killed my grandma okay
why did his erstwhile you for trolls
continue to sing depressing a song
apparently all the fantasy characters in
this fantasy movie grew up listening to
the same 1980s human power ballads I
just assumed you had a terrible voice no
no it was like an angel at least that's
what grandma used to say that's also
what Lou Pearlman said at this point you
could tell me I'm watching the movie
sing and I would totally believe you
don't you know anything about sarcasm I
think I had a talk at once will be
attempts to throw in a singular adult
joke but it's so obvious that their
punishments should be explaining the
birds and bees to every child who saw
this also this forces me to imagine at
orgasm it's just the third or fourth
time killing song montages movie has
made me suffer through I lost count
I'll just get my worthless scullery maid
to get another place setting ready for
the lovely lady mr. Spock
gristle only introduced Bridget as his
plus-one so the only way chef could know
her name is if the screenwriters were
committed to seeing Christine Baranski
to the hell out of this long laptop to
slow - what are we granting the reason
for this emotional renaissance - branch
sure he called the story about his
singing getting his grandma murdered but
it doesn't mean I'm sorry up stories so
big stupid yes help me be ready glitter
Sparkle Bridget should know that in
order to do this there will obviously be
no trolls to be served at ulfstead so
either way she screwed
and filmmakers really use the finest
vintage technology and music for this
workout montage between gristle working
up at Donna summers I feel loved Bridget
singing Lionel Richie solo branch
singing Bonnie Tyler's total clip to the
heart Kroll village singing Earth Wind
and Fire September and cool in the gang
celebration and branch and poppies Cyndi
Lauper True Colors do it was anyone even
thinking about the present day monster
casually stops months during long enough
for the trolls to assemble their escape
device how does this gate being
propelled exactly or steered I'm sick of
writing them you're sick of hearing them
but can we please rise above glitter
scream or is that just where we are as a
movie society you don't see that stuff
in Manchester by the feet all the trolls
survive this it can't be good
sorry papi we're too late yet another
fake out death for hippie troll Aldous
snow seriously we're really supposed to
feel anything for this character
he's been on screen for like two minutes
looks like trolls dis was traditionally
held out by the troll tree as kind of a
summer barbecue but now they're all
headed to the castle which definitely
doesn't look big enough to host the
entire town let alone for a formal
banquet now let's prepare the main car
Hopi needs to pick us I'd be a bonkers
fairy tale about a grim death for the
protagonists or a light-hearted
adventure for a pink Toyland are you
being sarcastic
Oh oh my god admit it you have expected
this character to poop himself out of
shock didn't you yes I wonder if a troll
loses its colour does it still bring
happiness to a burden that heats it
probably not right so why didn't they
just lose hope a long time ago and make
it useless for them to eat them also
aren't the cooks supposed to be
preparing the main course pretty sure
these trolls should be on a burner by
this point and I see your true mm-hmm
I've heard this is exactly what happens
to women and many men for that matter
when Justin Timberlake starts singing
this is nice a branch to lift everyone's
spirits and all but couldn't have gone
with a song that's more of a plan style
because as of now they're all still
gonna die and now they're all happy so
they're gonna be delicious
for the next machina seriously these
controls get amazingly lucky this whole
movie this is like Forrest Gump Ian
levels of luck I love you for that I
love you too Bridget for no other reason
this movie gives me except for
convenience there will be no fro until
the king
app1 has arrived well unless she doesn't
come at all but that's crazy talk who
wouldn't want to be with you chef is
acting like she's aware lady glitter
sparkles isn't going to show up but has
done nothing to make that happen or gain
that knowledge we did just ruined her
life to save ours it's not right that's
partly true it's not right but they're
actually probably going to kill her once
again how the hell is escape repelling
us out do you really think I can be
happy of course it's inside you it's
inside of all of us
I got this feeling bad my bone and by
inside you I mean this song will be
stuck inside your head for the next
three days
also it's obvious this entire movie was
just a setup for the song which was
released six months before this movie
came out in a cheap grab for the song of
the summer in 2016 wait what was I
talking about again got that good song I
must see all these bergens are still
hungry right it's the power of music
that much more than the power of hunger
because if it's 2 p.m. and I haven't
eaten there's no song in the
universe that's better than a Baconator
how the did all these trolls get in here
and we're already halfway through the
escape tunnel and the primary characters
were the only ones that crash through
the window I stopped Bergen does her
impression of your Aunt Linda when she
hears this song at Donna's wedding
reception all those cute happy little
troll just murdered someone
that's too adorbs hey Russell Brand roll
remember him no yeah I think he charges
by the minute and they've already blown
their budget on Timberlake oh yeah but
can he do that I mean he's still alive
at all can she continue to be the leader
as Princess feel like Daddy troll is
getting a little caught up in the moment
oh you think that's the end then you can
finally escape this nightmare and get
your kids to their dentist appointment
now no there's three three minutes of
b-roll troll singing credits to come
[Music]
well Papi's all sloppy how's the highway
I got a fever and the only prescription
it's more cowbell quick little errand
there hmm
that's juice high-five keeps asking me
to give him a high-five
I'm couldn't just even one high-five why
don't you try and some positivity a
little positivity might go with that
best it's a labor of love
[Music]
in the movie trolls the Birkins eat
controls every year in order to feel
happy that's the only thing that makes
them happy that's freaking sad listen I
can end this movie's conflict in seconds
the burden should sign up for naturebox
that gives them tasty snacks they won't
complain about and freeze the trolls
from being Birkin dude yeah and if the
bergen's over you were to go to
naturebox.com/tyler MSN's you can get
half off your first order which is
literally 50% off the snacks are always
rotating they replace anything you don't
like for free
literally what are you waiting for an
engraved invitation my ally whether your
tastes run from salty to savory to sweet
naturebox has you covered and it's all
healthy and good for you free of
artificial colors and preservatives and
all that crap denied just go to nature
box calm
[Music]
[Applause]
Nichola keep doing so look with nature
box and you'll start snacking healthier
by the day